if you can't love yourself how the hell
you gonna love somebody else can I get a
name it and
hi I'm Ashley Roberts my name is car
meet I'm Jessica Sarah I'm Kimberly
Wyatt its Nicole here and this is first
and last for Tyler the first person I
was inspired by II I would have to say
would be Whitney Houston I heard her
sing the greatest love of all and I knew
right then I was meant to sang a Paula
Abdul and Janet Jackson were it was my
mother she's amazing she's such a strong
fearless woman definitely was my mother
it's my mother and my father were
performers and I was just always
inspired by watching them perform and be
on stage and live their best live this
gorgeous ballet dancer named Adrian
canterna look her up on Instagram she's
still dancing she has a kid she's I mean
she still inspires me to this day the
last person I was inspired by
artistically right now musically if I'm
staying in that vein is Liz oh yes Robin
Antin who's the creator of Pussycat
Dolls she always gives me confidence and
she always makes me you know love being
a Pussycat Doll it's definitely my
daughter just shows me gratitude every
day is Jameela Jamil she's absolutely
incredible I love seeing the work that
she's doing and inspiring positivity and
empowering women and people is amazing
RuPaul I'm always inspired by RuPaul if
you can't love yourself how the hell you
gonna love somebody else can I get a
name it and I would have to say my first
real starstruck moment I think was
actually Whitney Houston Johnny Depp
owned the Viper Room I don't have a lot
of cartilage in my nose so I told him
that and then I started to make shapes
with my nose like a taco I used to do a
performance group when I was younger and
we were doing Annie one of the little
girls in the show her uncle was John
Travolta's so he came to the show and he
sat in the audience in the whole time I
was just cheating it up like I knew he
was out there and I ran offstage and I
jumped off and like went to him and
hugged him it was probably cute because
I was that age but now I'm embarrassed
for sure the kids on the block because
okay they're just so amazing so as a kid
I loved Missy Elliott she was my
ultimate and when we did a video with
her we did the song would she think
about that when she came into rehearsal
I about passed out
I'm on the mass singer in America and I
think my last starstruck moment would
have to be meeting Mouse you're gonna
figure out who that is you feel the same
way you'd be like yes legend what Queens
ass I was at the park with my daughter
and he was getting darker and there was
somebody else there who's there kind of
late with his kid we start kind of
chatting on you know from afar chatting
up and I get closer and I'm like hey
it's Christian Bale when I met Sarah
Jessica Parker on the red carpet at the
MTV Movie Awards and I made an idiot out
of myself telling her my name is Jessica
- Sam Smith was in the other day and he
said he's like a big fan of the dolls
but I still was like oh my gosh todrick
Hall I love him I DJ and I loved playing
his strikes they don't play them beats
like they used to they don't play them
beats the first song I learned might
have been pearly shells pearly shows
pearly shadows from the ocean from the
ocean shining in the Sun spotlight by
Madonna pose pose it was amazing let me
tell you it was either neverending story
theme song loved that or toto by Africa
you know when that chorus comes on in
his prince erotic City out of the blue
by Debbie Gibson I loved it I used to
sing it and pretend I was her with her
hat in the flower and her dimples I
loved her dimples the last song I
learned was pretty much probably reacts
react Lucy had olive Kizza dad's new
react actually react with the Pussycat
Dolls react
I did add them sprinkles on it hi I'm
Ashley Roberts car meet I'm Jessica seda
I'm Kimberly Wyatt its Nicole here and
that was first and last for Tyler
[Music]